I'm just a concerned citizen yeah I'll
stick you know someplace else the kid
is dead and the story who told you to be
out there what were you doing out there
hey you can't be back here yeah I
just got off the line with O'Bannon
he said that he needs to see you
at the station and some emergency
the hell you talking about I don't work
with O'Bannon I say O'Bannon I'm in ok
[Music]
it'sa whoa-whoa-whoa-whoa yeah I've got Jim hopper
[Music] [Applause]
[Music]
all right let's go good then we just
need salt lots of it how much is lost
fifteen hundred pounds where are
we gonna get that much salt [Music]
wait it's not gonna snow next week
is it worst case no school so this
is your plan work formula for
it in there come on trust me
they move [Music] all right let me do the talking
you just kill Mike I'm a chief
of police I could cover it up
you're crazy crazy you want to see
a real crazy you disrespect me again
why don't we cut you up into little pieces and
feed you to your pooches Shirley I'm afraid no
alcohol is allowed off the premises anything
those pills used to swallow my candy I can't
recall did you have a prescription for those how
about drinking on duty yeah we have some real
fun stories about that rather busy friend almost
told me last night so I'd say we're still not even
nice ring so you insane let's find
out okay because people gives me
things sometimes what kind of things money ah
[Music]
way to think you're going pal this is Todd he's
agreed to lend us his vehicle to transport our
dangerous criminal yes he fit very dangerous
at board room yeah chop murder chow we should
really get going hey how do I get my card
back you just call the station station
[Applause] [Music]